[Music]
y'all like 88 rising the crew I think
they're doing some great [ __ ] for the
community one of the stars in that group
is named Joe G you guys know him yeah I
love his great [ __ ] music right but
before that is that it is pretty very
emo that's his vibe very mellow emo I
know that he was a he was a youtuber
before that's what I know her mass yeah
you put the French started the Harlem
shake viral challenge really Oh ty
here's a pink guy would always wear that
pink in a cool pink suit guy she is okay
if 4chan was a human being that's jouji
i mean that's pink eye or that's that's
so his character right so he did a lot
of satirical [ __ ] back then and it was
like this vile disgusting it's like all
the shitty parts of the Internet in a
human being right and I thought that was
us well he's he's teased 4chan were more
like pornhub okay you're more like porn
maybe I am what would be be it what
would be are we more like reddit I think
we have X videos oh yeah what are we if
we had if he was 4chan what would we be
they read it read it I think so yeah I
think right it's a good one
okay we're right that sucks dude if you
only you guys knew that sucks
damn how all shitty read it is know just
how like lame redditors it's okay
- part of what pretty lame I mean yeah
we're pretty die mister you guys are
business suits on top and nothing on the
bottom but this is cool [ __ ] cuz I'm
trying to say I know I'm a rumor okay
not read it as boomer okay my bed maybe
we're a private Facebook group we're
Google Hangouts where you hang we're
Google hangout that's so sick whoa
that's tight
Wow all right so us of the older
generation know his character filthy
Frank pinkeye we enjoyed some of his
videos and his satirical character but
as he's a musician now you know and he
works with other kpop performers and
stuff like that there's a whole
generation of 12-year olds that don't
know who the [ __ ] pink guy filthy Frank
because not real fun is he just got pink
guys his character is called pink guy
uh-huh so Twitter there was a huge
trending of Joe G is over party food a
lot of k-pop fans this is uh this is one
of this the worst
angry they all [ __ ] like you they
used to like I would do like videos or
anyone that did the videos and you do
like BTS of this they would be tense
with BTS just BTS right like behind the
scenes of jakie news right they would
dislike no come with thousands and start
disliking the video you're trying to use
BTS the group as a cloud and stuff they
don't know what it means
yeah and they're like then anything on
Twitter like oh this guy got killed
right you go and all it is is just kpop
videos kpop videos because they're just
trying to spam they're like super loyal
fans amazing how do I get in all the
tagged BTS for every vlog now so you can
get extra views for no reason yeah um so
because people don't know what this
character is about right they just hear
the crazy things that he said and they
think that he's actually supporting
racism sexism all that stuff I guess
young people are just I don't know if
people in general understand satire
these days
okay I mean no probably that's what
satire is they think that's actually
Jojo and satire that was like very
political yeah I'd like for satire you
have to know what's happening you get to
it's all context right so if you look at
his character without context then it's
bad he did this stuff when these kids
weren't even born that's why they don't
have the contact seek it out know like
well they love you they love to counsel
about norihiro in general or just
reactionary hey I can't believe he
[ __ ] did this um so honest page right
he had to make like a disclaimer
back in the day I don't think he had to
do it
disclaimer cuz we all got the joke we
all got it but he says Bill T Frank is
the embodiment embodiment of everything
a person should not be he's anti PC
anti-social in anti health what spell
that cou he's not couth what's that mean
he's uncouth is what they say he's like
not not it's he's very uh rough around
the edges
okay not nice yeah it's like uncut
people don't say it much it shouldn't be
said much that jacket it worked
thank you very much so he behaves and
reacts excessively to everything
expressly to highlight the
ridiculousness of racism misogyny
legalism injustice ignorance which is a
good slumber for the bad comment I think
he's explaining him this is the
disclaimer of his channel right make
sense and I think I get that I gotta
leave people [ __ ] have to think he
had to do that when he's dressed in a
[ __ ] piece suit what I like that I
keep serious at least with that his
response wasn't like had I am sorry for
my actions back in the day he's like
literally like this is what it is you
know that's the state of just a satire
now is you have to say you know salad
eyes for the jokes that you did 20 years
ago
explained exactly like hi I am doing
satire now that is not that is not
censor I mean internet works like that
right people want you to to apologize
it's just they want to see that you've
evolved you know I mean obviously they
want to get outreach for the sake of
[ __ ] boredom or grinding it out rage
but I think they're also like well did
you change since then so then people
come out with like yeah I think he
doesn't she doesn't believe what the
character does right that's the whole
point of satire it's like Borat like you
make fun of the world by showing a
character that's kind of ignorant in
everyone exposing the people around them
nobody if you don't feel that way why
are you saying that's why is that stuff
coming out of your mouth what God do
backslash as an example of what not to
be no but she's saying that's what
people think the fact that I can bring
yourself to say things like that mums
you and some degree might agree with it
or it can back it up you must exactly
how many people are reaching like that
isn't that called stupid yes yes is
there like a stupid
especially with comedy trying to comedy
and trying to like actually push it
people are get the most mad because why
do you making fun of this stuff yeah I
mean yeah of course he making fun of
like racism it's it's to me it's funny
to make fun of ignorance so that's what
I don't understand you just educate them
you should be a good neighbor
everything should get the made baby made
fun of I just think that not
everything's gonna be funny that
everybody that's all so true
dogs poop I think that's hilarious I
love that so it's not that offensive you
see like he didn't like I don't like it
so it goes on to saying he also sets an
example to show how easy it is in social
media for any zany material to gain
traction and followings by simply
sharing unsavory and unsavory opinions
and joking about topics many find us
offensive there is no denying that the
show is terribly offensive but this
terrible offensiveness is a deliberate
and unapologetic parody of the whole
social media machine and a reflection of
the human microcosm that that is social
media
I like his statement I like that's the
statement and it's good as coming out
now it's not like he put this out before
having to explain yourself
this is after he's done doing that
character he moved on and he's Joji now
he's Joji and this is him not
apologizing but just informed people of
what the past was I hope a generation
gets raised not knowing Marvel stuff and
then there's a bunch of people who are
pissed that spider-man's manspreading
because when he's [ __ ] in the air fly
down with his legs he [ __ ] Babel it's
like nobody there he's like look at this
like crazy come in here and try to climb
on the wall and he just pulls these
[ __ ] panels down nobody says well
what I don't understand is that why are
people making their interpretation fact
about something that they see there so
it's like I always thought that art is
something that was subjective and not
objective it's up to interpretation
right so if they see something and they
might be projecting their own
insecurities or whatever and then
they're attacking the artists for their
own interpretation for what it is and I
don't get
I think arts all about both their now
creation and the interpretation of that
art like if you read a book and you see
it differently than your peer your
opinion about that book still matters
and that means that art working as its
intended right but are always has
context and I don't think people are
looking at the context because I've gone
to some [ __ ] museums and I'm and
that's when you're supposed to read the
Packard geo sometimes there's things
like and it's like what's the context of
this twenty thousand dollars right here
let's explain the economy in the current
state of the world right now don't you
kind of find it beautiful that we can
all look at the scene like everyone
looking at a bowl of fruit can paint
something a little bit different and
then somebody can react to it and go I
[ __ ] hate this picture this bowl
fruit and somebody else could be like I
guess the sickest picture of a bowl I
love that like I love I love all that I
think it's working as an opinion and all
that stuff is great what I don't like is
that bowl of fruit is offensive to me
take it out of the art gallery right
that's what I don't artists should never
get to make a bowl fruit again I hate
that [ __ ] yeah and I think that's kind
of where the climate is going is let's
cancel the [ __ ] out of Joe Joe G so he
never sings another song ever again and
we never purchase anything that he I
think whenever anyone is cancelled or
anyone likes those photos they should
take all of those people's accounts you
can't touch their phones you can do
anything have they ever ever said
anything racist or anything bad in their
life that the arguments complain about
be great yeah I mean how do you feel
about what if what they created was
dangerous what do you mean like what if
that piece of text is actually dangerous
like mine cos there's one that's
obviously racist and then there's stuff
that stupid that people just get mad
about that isn't yeah how do you
determine where's the mind the game
there's not true because it's it's we're
going into like hate speech art or
whatever yeah stuff like that like if
they if there's an extremist musician
who's like this is my [ __ ] expression
right so it's like a Nazi pond or
whatever all these things it's a very
small population of people that doing it
and then Twitter is there okay [ __ ] it
we're gonna make this [ __ ] [ __ ] viral
and we're gonna put this on the main
page harder
we are just gonna write about it but
it's only five people that are really
met I'm so with you man
I say we create a whole surveillance
state where these kinds of people have
their phones cleaned and examine and
check we go through their internet
history we have a big brother I like it
that's like really good that's catchy
that's catchy I'm working with it I like
it I'm vibing with it I rather go big
mother oh wow
familial maternal very nice brother
don't give a [ __ ] about what you do
Papa's good to the kids now I can just
as daddy instead did Big Daddy Big Daddy
that's pretty good
it takes a brave man to say daddy all
say that yeah I just think whenever you
put something out you should look at
yourself first
[ __ ] yeah every time I know and I expect
more out of these 12 year olds because
they're too judgmental I think they do
look at themselves and like I got great
blue hair today yep yesterday it was
pink time to cancel some people yeah cuz
if anyone's innocent it is a 12 year old
because they haven't made that many
mistakes yet but just watch [ __ ]
when you're a 30 and you had 10
different orgies and you [ __ ] robbed
the bank I'm gonna come after you we can
all relate except I had 12 different
orgies you know
[Music]